Welcome everybody to another amazing episode of Wellness Warriors.
Today, I have a fellow doctor, slash former chiropractor, and he's got a list of all kinds
of fellowships and certifications.
He's certified in anti-aging medicine, regenerative and functional medicine, board certified integrative
cancer therapy, certified in epigenetic, epigenetic clinical methylation and nutrigenomics,
which, you know, I'll know that I love this, canoezeologist with emphasis on botanical medicine
and homeopathy.
Dr. Kevin Conner is the clinic director at Conner Clinic in Minneapolis, St. Paul, is
all right?
That's correct.
Okay.
I grew up in Winnipeg, so.
Oh, great.
There.
We understand the weather and I now live in Florida, so.
One of the wise ones that you look out of this, right?
That's right.
I'm very excited to have you on here.
I looked at your website and I looked at some of the videos that you had and I was very intrigued
with the work that you're doing and definitely will use you as a resource because we always
have clients all over the United States and the world really, kind of looking for doctors
like you that can support them for their healing journey.
So tell us why cancer.
I mean, you know, you start off as a chiropractor and then here you are, you know, working with
cancer patients and a few Lyme patients as well.
So what happened there?
Well, it was just, it was an experience.
So I graduated as a chiropractor, but really practiced as a functional medicine practitioner
before that term existed, taking care of people with thyroid issues and hormonal problems
and adrenal function and things, always studied about rife technology.
So rife is a light-requencing generator and for some reason I was enthralled with that
technology and he even had it in my machine picked out that I wanted to buy at some time.
But all I do about it was, was it was for cancer.
So I wasn't seeing cancer patients at the time.
And then in the late 1990s, one of my patients came in and she was diagnosed with breast cancer
in both breasts and was given three months to live and did not want to do chemo or radiation.
So she literally said, if you can't help me, I'd rather die.
And that's what I knew I should buy a rife machine and give this thing a shot.
Well, she lived another 13 years and died of a heart attack.
So it was in that process that God really opened the door and pushed me through and really
revealed to me what I was supposed to be doing.
So I loved chiropractic, I loved taking care of people but I do there was just something
missing that I was supposed to do, better practice.
I graduated in 1986 and just felt that missing something for a number of years.
So I ended up selling my practice and my wife and at then time for children, but in the full
time missionary work, we worked on the Mexico and a mission Bible school or a orphanage.
And God closed the door on that, put me back in practice.
I just didn't know what it was to do, but I was supposed to be doing until, um, shark came
along and that's really launched my, um, my new phone practice in taking care of people
with cancer.
That's how it started.
Okay, interesting.
So I'll explain to our audience what a rife machine is and what it does and how it could
be beneficial for people with cancer or any disease for that matter.
Well, a rife machine is named after it's a original founder, royal rife.
It's a light frequency generator.
So it uses light frequencies at a specific frequency is to help destroy pathogens.
That was the idea.
From a quantum physics perspective, everything down to its smallest particle is a frequency.
It's energy that's vibrated in a frequency.
That's what quantum physics tells us.
And rife theorized, well, if you could hit cancer cells with their own frequency, could you
break them apart?
Could you cause a lysis of the cell?
Uh, that's what his experimentations involved.
He found some success.
He was business back in the 30s and 40s, early 50s, um, university of, I think it was
Southern California school of medicine sent him certain, some cancer patients.
He had success with them.
He actually won them a lot of awards.
But unfortunately in the early 50s, that's when the, uh, uh, American Medical Association was,
was just going after anybody that wasn't using pharmaceuticals.
And he was put on a business and he literally just gave up the ghost and quit.
Uh, and, uh, his, his information was lost for a number of years.
And then it was in the 1970s when it was picked up again.
Uh, some of his old writings were found, some of his old videos were found.
You could search for them on YouTube.
Uh, and some of that technology was put back together to use.
So the early machine that I used on that patient, you know,
back in the 90s, it wasn't nearly as powerful as the machines that we have now, uh,
with the freedom of information act, it turned out that the United States government,
after they stole all rights technology, tried to use it to actually create disease.
So if you could hit somebody with the anthrax virus frequency,
can you cause anthrax virus?
And could we use this in germ warfare?
And could we use this against the Soviets?
Well, it doesn't work that way.
If you hit somebody with the anthrax virus and they don't have anthrax,
it's not going to do anything at all to them.
If they did have anthrax, um, it would do nothing,
but to help stimulate an immune response against an anthrax and help the person.
So it doesn't cause disease.
So it didn't serve the military and with the freedom of information act,
all that became public to people like me, uh,
when they spent millions of dollars of our taxpayer money to map out all those frequencies.
So it became, you know, a blessing in disguise, uh,
and, but it's been able to help a lot of people.
So right technology bottom line is using light frequencies to help stimulate the bodies
immune system to, to fight back against a disease.
Okay.
So when you say light frequency, are you referring to like visible light that we see
or is it electromagnetic frequencies?
Well, visible light is in the electromagnetic spectrum.
So it is, uh, we are using, we are using a bulb.
What's called a Tesla tube, which is a gas-filled bulb.
Uh, so there's a lot of rife machines.
You could Google rife machines and there's some $300 rife machines that are using
electrodes.
That's not, that's not really rife technology.
It's still might be using frequencies that electric stem that your chiropractor or
your physical therapist is using electrical frequencies to help stimulate muscle
contraction or relaxation or decrease inflammation.
That's what use of frequencies.
But in this where you're using a different spectrum, using a light, uh,
it's going through a bulb through a gas-filled tube, um, that makes a difference.
And it's, uh, it's the frequency that you're using that makes all the difference.
So if let's, let's say breast cancer, there's certain, uh,
frequencies that have been found to that breast cancer can vibrate at.
So there's, there's maybe a hundred.
So there's a lot of frequencies.
So you could get, you could run those frequencies if a person has breast cancer.
You could run those frequencies that can help stimulate an immune response against
those cells that can possibly cause lysis of those cells.
Um, it certainly causes vibration of those cells, which will help your body recognize
them as the enemy.
And that's part of the problem with fighting cancer is that these are your old cells that
are in rapid replication.
And your body isn't supposed to kill its own cells.
So if you can get the body to recognize it as something other than a normal cell,
then if a person has a healthy immune response, they have a better chance of badly
treated at themselves.
I'm just saying, well, if you were to recommend a machine for somebody to use at home,
uh, or is it better for them to go to a clinic like yours?
What kind of machine do you recommend?
Well, interesting.
Cause when we first started out, you know, we, you know, I graduated as a doctor.
So people come to me, they pay for a visit and I do something that they leave.
So that's actually how we read our clinic with patients that had cancer as well.
So they come to us.
We would do an hour, two hour, three hours of the rife on them.
And then they would go home and they'd come back up.
They were in a, um, pretty, uh, a cute state of their cancer.
They might come back every day and do that.
So it really limited us to be able to only treat local patients.
Um, and it wasn't telling me at one patient that, um, this years ago,
he was given two weeks to live by Mayo.
We were in Minnesota.
So Mayo clinic is there us.
Mayo gave him two weeks to live.
It's kind of an interesting story.
Cause his son lived in California, flew back to, um, after a few days of hearing,
this flew back to be with his dad the last couple of weeks and to prepare for his death and such.
Um, so this gentleman came into us.
His wife heard about us.
He was extremely indifferent.
He's like, Hey, my wife just told me to come here.
I'll come here and do this.
We started treating him daily in the office.
What kind of dad did he have?
He had a pay credit cancer that had spread to the, uh, the suffocates and the stomach, I believe.
Um, he wasn't pretty bad shape.
He was pretty gray looking.
It was, he was not real healthy, um, and, uh, but he was very compliant, you know,
he was just very indifferent.
He didn't even want to know what we were doing to do with my wife told me to come here and, um,
he was, he was there all week long and it's, he said, Oh, I'm not going to be here next week
because my son is coming to town and, um, we're going to go hunting, you know, and he was actually
looking a little bit pinker by the end of the week and it was like, what?
What?
When he said that, I'm like, I'm like, Lord, why did you send me this guy and now he's,
okay.
All right.
Maybe you just sent him so he'd have one last hunting trip with his son and he'd be healthy
and I was quite positive I wasn't going to see him again and, uh, but then after being
gone that week comes in the next week, okay, I'm back and he just kept going and going
and about two years into his care, okay, he was still going well and he was down to a
couple of times a week he was coming in or something.
He said, Oh, do you have a clinic and, um, I forgot some, what's sunny place in California
that I said, uh, no, he goes, cause where are you, we just sold our house and we're moving
to our place in this California and, uh, and it was like, Oh gosh, what are we going
to do?
And literally it was one of those prayerful, uh, uh, moments for me because as I prayed
about, what am I supposed to do with this guy?
He's done so well.
You know, he's supposed to be dead two years ago and, uh, at a letter, there's one of those
God said, what would you do if you had cancer?
Well, I do, I'd bring one of these home and use it every night and it was like, well, why aren't
you doing that with everybody?
So I literally came to the office the next day and said, we're changing our whole plant.
We're not having people do it in the office anymore.
Everybody's going home with a knife.
That's the right thing to do.
It turns out it's cheaper for people than having to come into my office and pay for an office
visit every day.
So that's what we did and that was what eight years ago or something and, uh, so all of our
patients go home with a knife machine and do it at home, um, that's probably the biggest
thing that makes us different from like the Mexico cancer clinics and such is that I don't
believe you're going to be healed from cancer in three weeks of doing detox therapies or something.
I think it's a lifestyle change.
I think there are certain things that you can do forever.
It would be, it would be highly beneficial for you to stay doing those things.
I think the right is one of them.
Um, it's not a magic wand.
That's going to heal everybody, but it can certainly stimulate an immune reaction to a disease
and that's where I think it shurns.
Awesome.
So what is the machine that you use and recommend for your patient?
We use, uh, we use the true right, but we also use the GB 4000.
So we use both of those.
We typically if a person comes to us and already has a GB 4000 will work with them with that.
If they, um, if they don't have a knife already, well, you will use the true right.
It's the easiest one to program it.
It's the easiest one to use.
Um, so it's, it's, and I think it's, uh, it's a little, it's a little harder as far as, um,
it's longevity.
Uh, I use one at home that's eight years old.
I have not had a problem with it.
So they last a long time.
They're, they're hearty machines.
Uh, and they're really good.
Those are the only two that we use.
So some people come and say, I use this run.
I, I, I, we, I've used under ones in the past.
I've settled on these two because I think they're the most powerful, the most beneficial,
the most functional, the most programmable.
And the key to arrive is if you're not running the right program,
it's, it's, it's completely worthless if you're trying to do something.
If, if I have, um, a bacterial infection, I'm running viral programs.
It is not going to do anything for the bacterial infection.
Right.
The same thing with a cancer.
If I have a squabestelt cancer, and I'm running some other type cell cancer program,
it's not going to help.
So it's very specific to the frequency.
So program is essential.
Uh, and it comes with instructions.
So a layperson can learn how to use it.
Oh, yeah.
So person, we have patients that call us and go, I can't afford to come to you.
I can't afford to use your services.
But I think I could borrow somebody's rife.
Um, yeah, you couldn't use it on your own.
You could buy one right from the company.
Um, I'm not saying people need us.
You can, if you're going to buy a rife, I would highly suggest you only buy one of those two.
That's just my opinion.
It's not to bash any other company.
It's just I've used other ones and that's, that's my opinion.
And you can certainly use it on your own and get instruction from the purchaser
for the company, or we could help you as well.
Okay.
So true rife or the GB 4000.
Yes.
Okay.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Now, let's switch gears a little bit because another one of your specialties is
methylation, genetics, epigenetics, misogynomics.
And my audience certainly knows all about that because
one of the big aha moments I had in my healing journey
was my homocysteine was at 21 and I'm like, what is this?
Like I'm a heart attack waiting to happen.
I had no idea what homocysteine even was.
So that led me down the path of understanding the whole methylation process
did DNA testing and THR, blah, blah, blah.
You know, GST, glutathione, vitamin D problems, you name it, I had it.
So I had the perfect storm for creating breast cancer.
So tell me how you use genetic testing in your practice
and how you apply that with patients with cancer.
And why that's so important.
Well, let's start by saying I don't think that there's very many cancers
according to any reputable information.
Maybe 5% of cancer really is caused by a genetic problem.
But your genes do factor into a lot of things.
So the first thing that people think of when they think of genetics and cancer,
if they've stayed up on any knowledge is typically tumor suppressor genes.
So you have a certain fail-safe method in your body and your cells
to help if a cell goes into rapid replication.
So what cancer is is one cell going into rapid replication or some reason a
period of possible causes and that cell goes just starts to replicate
in those cells, replicate and replicate.
That's what cancer is.
So most people understand that everybody has cancer and by that definition is we all have cells that
do that. But then we have tumor suppressor genes that should sense that kick in and cause that cell
to go through, stimulates certain processes called capsases that stimulate apoptosis and cause
cell death. So have that protective measure in your genes called the tumor suppressor gene
that should kick in and cause cancer cells to die.
So if I have defects in tumor suppressor genes that can hinder that fail-safe method,
knowing that would be helpful because there are known things that you can do to help stimulate
increase in tumor suppressor gene function. So and that's well documented in the literature.
Give you an example of that's one of the benefits of curcumin.
The active ingredient of turmeric is it can, it's been proven to increase the P53
tumor suppressor gene system. So even if I have defects which we all do have some defects,
but even if I have growth defects in my P53 by tumor suppressor gene, made tumor suppressor
gene system, if I'm taking curcumin that can help that function a little bit better.
So knowing my genes prior to getting a serious disease can be helpful because I can take
nutritional, make nutritional changes, make dietary changes based upon those genes
and help prevent disease. And likewise, if I already have a disease, I have cancer. Why should I look
at my genes? Well, you same thing with tumor suppressor genes, but there's multiple other gene pathways
that are as valuable to look at. How are my detoxification pathways? How are my growth pathways?
And my stimulating K-ROS production, which is stimulating growth production with because of
these defects I have. So maybe I should be off of dairy or I should be off of it. So it can,
it can guide our our dietary choices. And I can certainly guide our specific nutritional
things that you'd want to pathways that you may want to support based upon defects that
we all have. So it doesn't mean you're going to get a disease because you have a defect.
It doesn't mean that you're treating that genetic defect because you can't. You're not going to
make a change in that gene, but knowing that I have defects in that pathway can help me make wise
decisions and help me overcome disease or prevent it. Now, what are your, well, let's talk about
breast cancer specific? Are there specific genes that you have seen that are involved
typically in the development of breast cancer other than the brackaging, which I'd like to ask you
about also, because we say bracka and everybody freaks out, but they don't realize it's a tumor
suppressor gene. It's a good gene. And why does it, why does it mutate? It doesn't, it's not always
genetic. So, well, let's address that breast cancer specifically.
So breast cancer specifically, there are certain genes that you want to look for for breast cancer.
Certainly, the two, the, the brackages are just one, those are tumor suppressor
genes, not it just in breast cancer, but any hormonally driven cancers. And what people struggle with with
the brackages is that typically if they go through their oncologists, they're only going to check
two, three, four, five of the main brackages where there's dozens and dozens of brackages.
Wow. And it, so most people will have multiple defects on their brackages and that that's just
can be very normal. So you have to be careful to, to call the person when you go over their genes,
because the person could be stuck in thinking that if I have a defect, I'm going to get a disease.
That's not true. So, but you definitely look at the brackages with any type of hormonally driven cancer.
And then you don't have to be looking at detoxification pathway genes. And maybe even more important
than the tumor suppressor genes, it's that detoxification pathway genes. And not just breast cancer,
but most cancers, because it is something, remember, something had to get inside the cell to cause
that rapid replication in the first place. Could it be a virus? Well, yes, it could be that it's really
not going to be affected by the tumor, or the detoxification pathway genes. But more often than not,
it's some sort of toxic chemical that we're exposed to, heads the, the rising cancers across the
world in the last 50 years, because the rise in chemical use and how that correlates. So it's the,
it's, it's the slowly of our detox pathways because of defects that is probably our biggest
genetic cause of cancer, though it's indirect. Yeah, makes, that makes absolute sense. Now,
what kind of genetic testing do you use? Do you have a specific company, or do you have your own?
We, it's not our own, but it is a company that we use that is only through professionals.
And it's through, I believe it's through Rutgers University. And it's still, it's one that tests for
the most amount of gene steps. We used to use 23 and me. We stopped using them because a couple
years ago, they cut their steps that they were testing for in order to make their test less expensive,
though they didn't pass on that cheaper expense to the, to the consumer. It made their,
they made their company more profitable, you should say. And, but they cut out a lot of the
steps that were valuable to practitioners. They saved the steps that were more ancestral,
orientated to compete with, you know, their main competitor. So we stopped using them. If a person
does have a 23 and me test that does fit into our software still, but we're missing a lot of potential
genes. The cost of the gene, the lab itself is, is pretty reasonable. I think it's about $200
for the lab to run a gene test. And then the software gives us a pretty hefty spit out of
probably about 60, 70 pages of detail of the genes that we want to look at.
And there's so many that, you know, I created a kind of a video book called Cancer Genes.
Have it. It's a free, you can watch it free on our website. But it's a series of, I don't know,
40, 50 videos on going through a gene report. And what you'd want to look for and how it,
how it correlate to not just cancer, but to other diseases and dysfunctions and struggles that people
have. And we never ever want to say that genes are the cause because they aren't. It's the
epigenetic factors that are the cause. But the benefit is the epigenetic factors are what caused
the mutations too. But certainly if the person has mutations, it can, it can, it can, it can,
it can create some problems. So if we can know that, I think it's just another piece of the puzzle
that can help a person. Excellent. Now epigenetic factors, what, what are, what are they?
Well, they're the same factors that any good functional doctor will talk about. It's just
eating, you know, healthy because you want to limit exposure to toxins that can not only cause
issues, but that can damage your genes. And one that most people don't want to talk about because it
can land them in trouble is things like vaccinations and medications, those toxins that your body has
to get rid of. We think, oh, it's a medication, it's a miracle of science that it can be. But
it's still a chemical that your liver has to detoxify on a pathway. And in itself, we have no idea
what that's going to do to our old gene pool. And if you still are having babies, you're going to
pass on that defect to your baby. And we have no idea what that's going to do down the road
a few generations. But that's what we're experiencing. Many people believe just you mentioned the MTHFR gene
defect. It's been studied and many people would agree with that defect quite possibly was caused by
synthetic folate put into our bread and our flour back in the 30s and 40s. And it's still in our
cereals today, folic acid, which is synthetic methyl tetrahydrofolate. And that quite possibly has
caused the MTHFR defect, which now causes a decrease in methyl product production for a lot of people.
Never thought of that piece, but that makes total sense because you look at the increase in that
problem and you look at my generation or our generation, our parents grew up in the 30s, 40s and
I grew up in the 50s. And yeah, all that synthetic food and synthetic vitamins that were in the
breads and cereals makes perfect sense. What other kinds of foods would be beneficial from an epigenetic
point of view? Beneficial for cancer patients? Yes. Well, it's more so what foods are probably best
to stay away from from a genetic point of view. And certainly with any cancer, you're trying to
limit growth. So then you look at what foods stimulate growth pathways, metabolic pathways,
and the first one that you should probably consider is dairy products. So dairy, I wouldn't say dairy
is necessarily a cause of cancer per se, but it certainly is a stimulant to growth factors.
Try to explain to people what is dairy for its milk for a baby for a 60 pound cow to grow up to
via 1200 pound cow. We certainly don't want to be adding growth factors. And I show in videos
different men of the metabolic pathways to get them to understand that stimulates the K-ROS pathway,
which is a growth pathway. To get them to understand the technical side of that, but staying away from
things that will stimulate growth of the cancer. So then we talk about from a dietary standpoint,
cancer needs a fuel source. So whereas dairy is not necessarily a fuel source, it's a growth
stimulator. But what is a fuel source of a cancer? It could be fed mainly directly through the pathway
called glycolysis, which is how we break down glucose. So sugar should probably be something that
all cancer patients should refrain from. But there are certain people that their cancer is stimulated
completely off glycolysis. Or that's the main source of fuel we could say. And then there's
other people that their cancer currently is fueled off of amino acid, gobbling up amino acids, and that
is the fuel source, lysine, and methionate, and glutamine. So those people should limit
animal products like meat. That should be the main thing that they limit. That they should be
eating a bunch of carbohydrates, but they really have to limit protein sources. And typically it's
animal animal proteins. So it can vary. Some people really should be eating some animal proteins,
and some people should not be eating any animal proteins. Probably every cancer across the
board should stay away from dairy. Every cancer across the board should stay away from gross glucose,
sugar, sucrose, has really no nutritional value. But some people don't need to stay away from
fruit. And vegetable juicy, which can be high in glucose breakdown, but has all these other
nutritional values. And if their cancer isn't fed directly through glycolysis, that's where juicy
can be very beneficial for those people. So it does vary from person to person, not so much cancer
to cancer, but person to person on the fuel source of that cancer. Can you determine this through
the DNA testing? You could get hints through the DNA testing, yes. Dr. Godzillais and Dr.
William Kelly did a questionnaire testing, metabolic testing, they called it. We do kinesiology
testing as well to help determine that. A person not having any access to any of those things could
look at how they feel after they eat those things. I don't feel as well when I'm juicing
or if I don't eat some meat, I don't feel well at all. Those are some hints that you could gather
for what is possibly causing your cancer growth. Certainly, if you have a tumor that's visible
and palpable, you can tell sometimes when what you're eating is adverse to the cancer.
So there's different ways that you can tell what's what's currently feeding your cancer,
but you want to try to cut off that pathway as much as possible.
Well, I could go on forever. I love all this science geeky stuff. I think it really helps us to get
to the root cause of what cancer is. And you know, what I educate our community on is you don't have
to fear cancer. Once you understand what it is and what it's not, then we have all these tools
available to us that can really allow the body to heal and recover from cancer. So thank you so
much for everything that you do. And I understand that you have on your website. What's your website?
It's Cutters Clidic. See, oh, added ursclidic.club. And you have some free books that we can access
there. I looked at them with some great information there. So thank you so much for everything
to do Dr. Conner's. I appreciate your time and your expertise. And I'm going to be in touch.
All right, thanks for having me. Okay, thank you. Bye bye.